hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to another try not to
laugh this times gonna be different this
time we're gonna win I'm gonna win I
don't know what you guys do I imagine
that you guys fail more than I do
because I might be a giggly [__] but I
imagine that you guys are even more so
of a bit of a big-league itch all right
what have you got big boy
[Music]
[Applause]
no niner-niner we need backup we're
sending a chopper now better get on his
beach no funny
I'm sorry that'd be just stealing noodle
that's amazing that's just a stupid
Boulder I hate you yeah I feel attacked
[Music]
very cute yeah I don't think you were
supposed to do that at all hey yo big
guy gang if your thighs be dummy thick
duet this a couple of hams right here
got a couple of hams lemon then some
hams Wow okay okay do you want to relax
do you want to detoxify do you want us
to be soothed do you want a coconut
I'm sorry wait what why is that that's
not funny I come over to drink this
water okay it's water fountain I go and
press it it's come water why is it white
that's so not funny
[Music]
I'm sorry I I feel like that would have
made me laugh if it hadn't been so
goddamn surprising
[Music]
I need a minute to myself
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm gonna die this is the one that's
gonna get me this business let's go kill
me let's go kill me I'm gonna die
ah yeah sampling sampling sampling
siblings this is my sister this is my
brother we are siblings that we care for
each other everything we own we always
share
[Music]
- shouts - shakey-shakey walk and give
without any voltage ey
hi told me it almost made me laugh and I
don't know why that's not funny Brad is
dick and twist yet oh my god this is an
MMA fight push the stop being you the
old [__] that's my move
that's my move oh yeah
I don't count that one I don't count
that that's not it but I didn't laugh no
I've seen this before it's just because
my weakness has been eroded my strengths
my resolve has been eroded with the
previous videos it's not my fault that's
not my fault that's not my fault I knew
God mad at myself
oh Jesus I think there's enough enough
for one day all right I lost again I
didn't even try I I don't even feel like
I tried so I don't know I'm a failure in
every way except the ones that matter so
thank you everybody so much for watching
hope you enjoyed this one hope you
didn't laughs if you did I'm sorry I'm
really sorry but hey you can make it up
to yourself by watching the other try
not to laughs that I have linked in the
description below or over there and the
suggested videos oh I just tugged my
headphones also did you know that I have
a story podcasts called the edge of
sleep if you like spooky stories I'm
it's it's good it's in the description
check it out it's called the edge of
sleep it's really fun and new cloak gear
Hey look at this I've got a long-sleeve
tee it's got some secret Morse code
written right here
who knows what Oh got it it it again Oh
such an [__] I can't even plug my own
merch right anyway thank you guys love
you lots
hey let's do another reverse charity
livestream real soon if you don't know
what that means keep it a secret don't
tell anybody about it because it
absolutely is a closed Club thanks
everybody so much for watching if you
want to see more of these let me know in
the comments down below and if you got
other funny videos that you want me to
see
send it to me thanks again everybody for
watching now as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
you